[音楽]
みなさんこんにちは
皆さんは何に興味を持って生きていらっしゃいますか
私はユニークな人に興味を持っています
例えば人のことなんて全然気にせずさっきの大塚さんもそうですけども人の目を気にせ
ずにそのままの自分の在り方でそれを出してしまう
ちょっと変わった人です近づきたくないなっていうような
そんな人達に興味がありますそしてそんな人たちに愛着を湧かせてしまうんです
ユニークな人たちに興味がある
そういうことからか偶然なという要因によってなのか
私は今遺産発掘プロジェクトロケットというプロジェクトをやっています
画面に映っているこの人たちが今4期生まで応募をかけているところなんですけれども
彼らがやりたいことをやり続けて得意な歳の社会の中で潰されずにそのままの状態で
生きていきが活き生きていられるそんな風にサポートするという活動をしています
ん
好きな事が
あってそれが学びの根底にあってそういったことがどんどんどんどん深まっていた時に
いつのまにか仕事になっている
そんな状況を作れたらきっと社会の中にはイノベーションを起こしていく多様な価値観
のある人たちが触れるんじゃないかな
そんな風に思ってユニークな子どもたちのまあビオトープみたいなものを作っています
ロケットにはやりたいことがあって仕方がないっていうそういうアクの強い子どもたち
が集まっています
彼らにははまってしまうものがあるんですけれども
そのハマり方が尋常ではないんですね
例えば水路に興味があるという子どもがいます
彼は1日中学校にも行かずに水路と母をいったりきたり
徘徊しながらずっと川の流れを水の流れを研究しています
初めて会ったときには僕はダムが決壊したときの水の流れが研究したいんです
時間がないんです焦ってるんですどうにかしてくださいって言って泣きながら
空港で大声で叫んでいます
4年前に出会った子どもです
あんなにはまっていた水路の実験ですがどうやら卒業したらしく今は全く研究してい
ません
彼が今ハマっているものはインターネットの光の流れの速さ
それにはまっています
そしてまたハマり方が尋常じゃないんですね
毎日毎日電気屋さんに行ってこれぐらいの束になる
パンフレットを持ち帰って読み込んでは電気屋さんに質問に入って質問攻めにして挙句
の果てにはもう店員さん顔負けの説明ができるくらいのそうでそれぐらいの専門的な
レベルに入ってしまいました
彼にとっては流れであったらなんで向かったんです
水路でも光通信でも
そんなふうに自分の好きなことを一点集中して深堀りしていく彼の姿を見ていると
自分独自の学びを続けてるんだそんなふうに思えて
なんだか滑稽に思えてきてしまってかわいいなと思って笑ってしまいました
彼がきっと大人になる頃にはもしかすると血液の流れや思考の流れや
そして人の流れに興味まで持ち始めて流れっていうキーワードだけでいろんな分野に
江東たずしていきながら
医学とか思想とか哲学とか政治とかそんなものにまで手を擦っ
手を出していくんじゃないかなというふうに楽しみになります
その他の子供たちもいろんな興味を持っている子供達がいます
きのこ博士のような子供も言いますしロボットやロケットや数学の素数や虚数
宇宙に興味があるっていう高額子供がいます
彼らの興味やまだいいんです
例えば動物の交尾にしか興味がありませんっていう子がいます
交尾のビデオ何時間でも見られます
どれが見たいです勝ってくれたときにはさすがに苦笑してしまいました
それどころか毒物の毒性のある生物に興味があって
武器に興味があってこれ使ったら何万にも殺せちゃうんですよねってうすらフライされ
た時にはどういう動揺してしまって返す言葉がなかったこともあります
そんな彼らを持つ親は内心ヒヤヒヤしていると思います
将来この子たちは不適合者になってしまうんじゃないか
犯罪者になったなっちゃうんじゃないだろうか
ホームレスにはならないだろうかそんな風に願って一生懸命興味をどうかを死なせて
ほしいというふうに願うんです
でもそんな親の思いはつゆ知らず彼らは何かに没頭していってどんどんどんどん自分の
学びを貪欲に深めていってます
そんな姿を見ると自分自身の新しい道を開拓していく
まさにパイオニアの姿ななっていうふうに思います
普通という基準から大きくずれながらも自分の中で大事だと思うことに邁進する彼らの
姿はとてもユニークであるし
そして幸せそうだしそしてなんといってもイサギがいいなっていうふうに思えてくるん
です
そんな彼らも普通の基準に照らし合わされるととてもしんどくなるときがあります
それが学校なんです
現代の学校の中に入ってしまうと標準の基準からずれてしまった
普通ではない子供たちというふうに見なされた子達は普通になるように強制されます
まるで生きづらさを抱えた絶滅危惧種のような状態になってしまうんです
そんな中で学校では普通になるように言われてしまいます
当然のように学校に行きなさいと言われますし
他の子と同じように漢字を書きなさい授業ちゃんと聞きなさい
そうしないと6ノートなにならないわよそんな事言われながら彼らは普通になることを
強制されていくんです
その中でどんどんどんどん研ぎ澄まされていたあのとんがった部分が削られていって
しまうんです
見るうちに
生き生きとしていた目からは活力が失われていってしまって好きなことに没頭していっ
たあの姿が失われてしまうんです
社会が求める普通っていったい何なんでしょうか
人は何を普通という風にとらえてどこに向かわせようとしてるんでしょうか
そもそも一人一人全く違う人間のはずです
私はユニークな人が好きです
ユニークっていう言葉には他と違うっていう言葉と
唯一っていう言葉があります
どちらも好きなんですけれども唯一っていう言葉の方で見るとどの人もやっぱり
ユニークな人なんですねそう思えてならないんです
私は生まれた時から実は
とても変わったおばあちゃんと一緒に暮らしていました
+潤の女の子たちがおばあちゃんのことを
おばあちゃんってさぁすっごい優しくってさ
本当にホッとするんだよねそんなふうに言っているイメージを全く共感できずに真逆の
おばあちゃんと一緒に暮らしていました
自分勝手だったし倫理感はないしとても強欲で
どうしようもないそんなおばあちゃんでした
でも根っからの悪人ではなかったんです
そんなおばあちゃんの隔世遺伝が私に映らなくてよかったなって本気で思っています
だけどそんなおばあちゃんを反面教師に思えたから私は小学校の時から正義感に溢れる
子供になりました
小学生時代私はおばあちゃんの悪事をもう
全てさらけ出しておばあちゃんと全力で戦おうとそういうふうに誓っていました
ですが中学校に入った時私はミッション系の学校に行ったんですけれども
初めて宗教というその宗教という授業を受けることになります
家では天台宗のお経を読んでたんですけれども
学校ではキリスト教の賛美歌を歌っていて
なんか妙だなと思いながらも
宗教の授業にのめり込んでいきました
そしてもう犯的に行きたいとおばあちゃんの反動から思っていた私は正しく生きていた
のが評価されたのかそれとも友達にからかわれただけなのかもしれないんですが
カトリックいいんというそういう良いに異名されました
またその中で聖書を読んで授業をちゃんと受けて宗教の勉強を高得点取らないという
そういう意識に入っていったんですね
で授業中何度も何度も先生が同じことを言うんです
結局6年間同じことしか言われなかったっていう記憶があります
要するに何を言ったかというと
ありのままの隣人を愛しなさい
そして十字架を背負って茨の道に遭い茨の道を歩んできなさい
そんな風に言われたんですこれ一辺倒だったんですね
れその時私はいつもおばあちゃんのことを思っていました
隣人じゃなくて祖母だけどなーって思いながら
好きとか嫌いとかそんなことを越えて愛さないといけないんだ
何かいつも消化不良の思いが残っていました
けれど次の週にはまた同じ事を言われるんです
毎週毎週シスターから同じことを教えられ続けて
卒業する6年後には私の考えはすっかり変わっていました
私がおばあちゃんのもとに生まれたのは上坂神様から与えられた
まあミッションなんだぷ
私が変わるって言うことが試されているんだ
そんな風に超ポジティブな考え方に変わっていました
これって本当に宗教の洗脳だなって思うんですけども
でもそんな風に変えようのない環境の中でいると
相手を変えるんじゃなくて自分のトライ方を変えて違いを受け入れていくしかないん
です
そんな風にして
まあ幼かった私は
身近にいるまあ変変態的なおばあちゃんを受け入れるしかなかったですね
でも今思うと
身近にそういったまあウイルス的な人間というかアクの強いそういう人がいたからこそ
私の中に変人レセプターというか変な人が来ても大丈夫っていうそういうレセプター
みたいなものが出来上がって今こうしてものすごくアクの強い
オタクな子どもたちがどんどんどんどん空気を
読まずに話してきてもそうだねって受け入れられるように付き合えるようになったん
じゃないかなって思ってます
そういう意味ではおばあちゃんに本当に感謝しています
そんなわけで小さい時から変な人に興味を持って育ってきたわけなんですけれども
変な人に会えば会うほど何が普通なんだろうって疑問に思うようになってきました
特に剣城と障害その境目を分けているものって何なんだろう
それを考えさせられるようなことがありました
私は10年ほど前に認知心理学という学問を学んでいました
それは人の言動が違ってしまうっていうのは世界の捉え方が違うんじゃないかな
そんなことに興味があったからです
自閉症の子供とそれから健常の子供さんにお絵描きの課題という日実験を行ってもらい
ました
シンプルな線を繋げていくこういう会です
まさに家の会や雪だるまの絵
これをなぞっていくその違いを見るという課題でした
皆さんだったらどんな風になぞりますかちょっとな撮ってみてください
いろんななぞり方をされる方がいると思うんですね
大抵屋根とか壁とかドアとか窓
それから煙突こんな風に複数の線を一つの概念として
そしてそれを集合体として家を描くその書き方が健常児と言われる普通の子供たちの
書き方でした
ところが自閉症の子は明らかに違う書き方をするんです
彼らは無意味な線
そのつながりであるっていう風に家を捉えていたんですね
それを分析しているときに私は思いました
通して社会でうまく生きている普通って言われる子どもたちは
線のつながりであるはずのものを屋根とかドアとかそんな概念でもってトップダウン
資金処理してしまうんだろう
それのほうがなんか自然界の中でが異常なんじゃない
どっちが普通でどちらが普通じゃないのか
正直なところわからなくなってしまったんです
同じものを見ているのに
捉え方が違うと行動が違ってくる
しかもそれを献上とか
障害とかそんな大きなくくりでくくって違いを明らかにするということに何か違和感を
感じました
生まれた環境や育った経験いろんな人との出会いの中で
本当は一人一人違う物差しを持っているそういうふうに思ったんです
今私たちが日常の中で感感じている普通というその外ねそれ自体も
文脈外国異なってしまえば全く違うものになってしまいます
例えば障害もそうです
他の民族の中に入るのもそうです
他の動物や時代を違えば全く違う普通になってしまうわけです
いつだって当たり前とか常識っていうものは基準が振れていく
そんなふうに思います
認知心理学を学んで
私は2つの矛盾することを支点としてもらったように来てもらったような気がします
一つは人間として
まあ普遍的に共通した認識パターンで世界を見ている
ということです
もう一つは
それ以上に
人間の中でも様々な一人として同じ物差しを持っていない
違う見方をしているというこの2つです
ロケットには
39アドケットには
独特な絵を描く子どもたちがいます
3 d の立体を3次元に綺麗に落とし込んでものすごく細かな霧絵を描く子どもたち
がいます
彼女が入ったことがあります
先生私悩みがあるんです
実は階段からよく転げるんです
なんか怪談の線が見えないんですよね
って言いました
もしかして彼女が美しい二次元の切り絵をかけるって言うのは
切り取れるっていうのは日常生活の見ている世界が二次元に近いような状態なんじゃ
ないだろう
そんな風に思ったんです
彼女らと私の見ている世界は全く違う
そんな彼女たちの世界をもっともっと見たいと思いました
ユニークな子どもたちに興味を持ったからこそ
私が知らなかった世界に彼女たちは連れて行ってくれます
そしてそこで新しい視点や価値観
そんなものを広げていくそれを手伝ってくれているような気がしてなりません
それがまた楽しみで
楽しみでランチ方がないというところにもあります
それは突き詰めれば私と彼らが違う
そのことに由来しているからだと思います
だからこそ普通っていう基準にブラされることなく自分の中にある世界を見ているその
基準でもってどんどん突き進んでほしいなって思うんです
他の人と圧倒的に違うそのユニークユニークさを持ってそのまま進んでほしい
そういうふうに思います
一方で
私たちのようにま規範的な意識や
見えないその常識にとらわれてその枠で生きている人たちにも言いたいんです
まあ会場の中にもどちらのタイプの人がいられるチャルのかわからないんですけれども
ユニークな子供の話をしてるんじゃないですよっていうことを言いたいんです
皆さん他人ごとじゃなくて自分の中に
他の人とは違う見方の基準を実は持っているんです
それをものすごく大事にしていった先に
実は変だと思っているちょっと自分とは違うと思って1000匹していた人たちの底に
つながる延長線上が先にあるんじゃないかなっていうふうに思うんですね
そう一人一人が思えると
社会はもっともっと変な子供たち
変な人たちに興味を持って関心を持って
そして優しく制することができるんじゃないかなっていうふうに思います
今日登壇していたユニークな人たちもそうです
彼らもすごく生き生きと潔い生き方をしてます
その生き様の先にとっても私たちが見たことのない素晴らしい世界があるんじゃないか
なってそんなふうに思うんです
だから皆さんも是非
恐れることなく自分の基準を受け入れながらその先にある新しい世界を一緒に見に行き
ませんか
以上ですどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]